on november 7th at 7 pm you can light
the night
with the leukemia and lymphoma society
and findlay automotive group
rocky joined the team to discuss the
years this year's virtual walk
[Music]
tyler we're back here we are thanks and
welcome to finley toyota
thank you another partnership another
way you guys are helping the community
so tell us what you're doing now yeah so
today i want to talk a little bit about
the leukemia and lymphoma society and
this is one of our
our pet projects this is a charity we've
been involved with for a long time
i was their board uh chairman back in
like from 2008 for like four years
ever since that time we've been
supporting them and all their
fundraisers and their events
one of their big events is the man woman
of the year the reason we're at findlay
toyota today is because we've won
the man woman of the year a findlay
employee has uh
three times in the last few years two of
them were from findlay toyota
john barr and anthony vardy and combined
they raised about 450
000 that money goes toward blood cancer
research and
we're trying to find a cure for blood
cancer we've made tremendous progress
it's been a lot of improvement in
survival rates and so forth
and so one of the big events that they
have every year is their light the night
walk
i was the chair for it a couple years
ago we had a big year we raised like 750
000 and it's all going toward blood
research and we want to make sure we
don't lose that momentum and this year
there are challenges because
of covid and having that event so i
wanted to introduce you to katie daley
from the leukemia lymphoma society
let her tell you a little bit about how
we're how we're doing the light the
night walk this year
thank you so much tyler nice to meet you
thank you so nice to meet you and thank
you for all your support tyler
so we made it yes a little different
this year true how are you guys going to
do this
so it's really just like everyone else
we are going to be holding our event
virtually
but as we are a community event with so
many aspects
we are still including all of that we're
going to have our remembrance pavilion
where we can honor those we've lost to
cancer we're going to have our survivors
circle
for any cancer patient or survivor can
share their story
and we're going to have our support area
where you can turn around
you can take a selfie post it on social
media to show your support for light the
night
oh that's good yes and we always end our
events with
an incredible fireworks display you're
also going to have the ability to
down download an app and celebrate with
fireworks as well
wow so you're making it interactive yes
that's always good and
how can people actually join you guys so
what they can do is log on to
www.lightthenight.org
snv for southern nevada and it's free to
register and participate
awesome and how much money are you guys
trying to raise this year we are trying
to raise
500 000 this year to fight blood cancers
okay well thank you so much for your
service i wish you the best of luck
thank you tyler thank you
and we're getting ready to like like the
light walk
and we want to thank findlay automotive
group for being one of our community
pride partners
lot